oh yeah Zack that kind of confidence you
know I'd say either one of these players
the poor players that we have left on a
tournament I think would be a worthy
adversary going up against the seven
monsters that we have qualified for a
world Invitational team I want to see
like I want to see all how can you not
watch this stream and not want boom to
just win the whole thing in my opinion
he's had the best pop off he had the
best emotion going into a big victor
collectively yes all of them you know
even though the Tiger Woods his pump you
know just a little uh let me get that he
has her he has a reef he has you know
the rage that he has he collected
fist-bump he has them all
all right either way we're gonna get
into this big matchup here this is again
our winners finals so because of that we
have a longer set of three out of five
much like we expected these two players
using their characters we have seen with
the IV pick and party wolf with killer
oh my god it's actually a year later the
Dreamhack Atlanta finals the run back of
the bag all right here we go there's a
new stages new mechanics coming up on
the way what boy but he's like you
alright yeah he's good lame like he had
yeah he has to be this way alright it's
one waiting for these opportunities a
boner but a big read there but party
whooping look at this damage oh man he
is hitting with the big stick
look nice and a step in a big punish
there with the lead all here is reversal
it's safe so enough time to get the
evasion just in case just out of range
for that normal throw and that's the
thing is that's always the bigness when
you go for a worse ledge against Ivan
you just get the watch out for that
and the party wolf had the right idea
he's been setting up his opponents for
that all day with a quick micro back -
into whatever move except Christmas tree
kind of covers all of that space yeah
it's an important holiday so he's gonna
need to switch it up for save nice able
to get the bullseye the follow up here
tying up the route party wolf right now
with the momentum here both of these
players have access to meter ants full
charge now let's see what they do with
it all right
again a lot of whisperers coming in from
San I don't know what the deal is on
that pool party but we'll continue
gladly to take advantage of the
situations presented tool might be going
short run away let me charge it up and
swinging low party does have the life
here it's gonna be on st. to see how
he's gonna be able to you know cover the
gap oh nice the thing is it's so scary
with my sword you do nothing you gonna
get humped up by your ankles and then
hopefully not have any complications
with that very finicky wall over there
buddy so punish all the Christmas tree
the follow-up here but nice stuff there
from st. able to push off party roll oh
and there was an opportunity there boy
unfortunately he's gonna go down and get
caught out by that babe two rounds to
one right now same with the lead again
this is a longer sense race to three
matches
wanna share nothing too big again keep
talking it up Christmas tree I love you
guys safe pushes you right out oh that
was baking not over the counter right
over there grab it says screen started
to go dark and almost like they knew but
guess what
I got scared I got scared oh here we go
nice step the balance party well if I
would have been exceptionally there I
fought all for surely that ring out to
us coming but o'clock the punish and the
death who are you
base party wolf and he's here to play
that was ridiculous geez he made that
meter worthy ah
anyways we're gonna go here into the
final round of match number one yeah
that was so to keep I feel like I'm
still thinking about a to eg string up
Legolas instincts instantaneously nice
check no don't side stuff come here up a
soul charge lot of damage to be done oh
my what you gonna do here get the ball
through with a 6 K goes to the low kick
oh nice I like that
what's the interrupt on ya didn't want
to deal with that situation it gets to
lethal hit the set things off along
damage pushing towards the edge of the
stage here it takes the takes the life
back
big stick little stay s ain't got a jump
right out of that I've seen that before
that's gonna close it out and look at
that party while taking match number one
here just
Frank's keep the blue light the bark of
a very talented player ever to just hit
those consistently in flood situations
especially since closing out sets that
arounds have been an extremely finicky
babe here understand it's not longer
said this kids winters final so you are
getting the 3 out of 5 yeah then you
guys gotta understand me I mean Elite is
nothing in this game nothing it doesn't
matter it's not over until you actually
see them in the loser's bracket that's
when you know it's over
right here we're gonna go into a rematch
here different stage of course but still
IV and killer going at it party wolf
advantage here played brilliantly that
opening game had clutch moments key
ducts where he was able to capitalize
and just take those rounds away but Sade
hasn't really shown his what he got yet
he hasn't really chose his brilliance
here in the matchup well if he shows all
the presents like that for free then
part of one's gonna get that one is
every single time trying to pick it up
just outside of he pins suggested you
extra this time since he already know
what he was giving up though you know
for your kid you have this present you
know what's in this box that's not a
person said it but surprise it wasn't
what you thought no not at all
all right party wolf again continuing
that dominance from the earlier set now
off another round here one matching one
round in his favor push them out still
inside good luck Christmas tree they're
successful Wow and just white in the
sweet spot where the entirety of the
boobs is with or even on a crouching
Keeling Castle and nothing's gonna whip
about that summer
suffering baby II would love to see
just moving away towards the middle the
stagers towards the center okay Billy
second it not able to do anything out of
it here it hits the Sun yeah looking for
a quick rise out of saying but
unfortunately not sold charged pop it up
still very much alive in this now but
this evil killing all see how he's in
the Death Zone he's got to be very
careful how he's gonna utilize that oh
my gosh see that oh just like best
lightest of steps able to thread that
needle in went for the last hit on that
he putting it on the work flow into that
yeah absolutely and now he got caught
stepping and follow-up come here is
getting a lot of damage
oh I like the idea but a little too in
misty lake was that 2 equals you have a
set distance
you have some of characters to say the
least in the series like a bang out of
the ring
here we go was now sane reading the
title to say everything just trying to
get into the head of party wolf what run
up throw our wolves gonna remain unfazed
quit sweeps gets the follow goes for the
low but a good block there for party
wolf flipping them over to the other
side with the couple points in that
situations are trying to step forward
and they keeping it bid right though so
make sure that st. isn't ducking any
future setups that he wants to go for
Wow and gets the Pope he press the
button first got to love that extension
same idea quicker execution better
utility on the move density I looking
for another guard brick greedy but at
same who's gonna stay disciplined oh my
god the unblockable with the follow-up
pardon will put yet another chance
oh man he does that meet her though he's
gonna have the utilize in it some point
here I'm just gonna take a punish of the
regular variety sidestep into three
point three piece but my SOI just
throwing me off it stays to play it was
of a character yeah you know he's gotta
be Haiti that's that situation that he
just put himself in I mean he had beat
her did it try to utilize it at all but
he ended up losing that round which was
key he could have tied it up there we
are opposed to car break territory
yeah I mean for everyone who's yeah just
want to see all these players do well
look at the bracket what do we one could
make it out only one who will be the
representative of the LCQ ace the
challenge our existing champions here
here we go match number three and we of
course are all tied up
alright starting it off transforming
stage here depending on the rounds table
impossible we're back to back third
time's the charm
oh right back at so you want to play
these games I got something for you here
you try to interrupt there but a nice
wake up there for watching the situation
though didn't get the connection he was
looking for us away whiffs and it's
ain't able to get a punish and stand
stab him up jumping yep spits four days
at this point that's the lone prison
treat save options with a good block at
the funny so easily magics crazy it's
not gonna be enough to kill it a little
bit more at Wow big swing big swing you
don't looking before the sidestep in
that situation I get with a slow slow
bag you know understand make sure it's
savory right absolutely
here we go partner was doing a great job
there try to use the evasive attack not
able to get anything out of it again one
way to solve it men give out those
presidents or something here Wow
that jumps over looking for the
crossroad I haven't get in again
particle chips I don't know maybe maybe
it's fuzzy blocking there something I'm
not entirely sure but we haven't seen
this the whole tournament and it's like
okay but maybe he has an itch who knows
ain't no telling xbox of course doing
his best Santa Claus
Wow oh maybe that was the tech sorry run
a stretch go ahead what's to everything
hey get him out of there early on this
is still looking for this off - he's
flash ducky I want to say
okay the last seconds roll to get up out
of their party wolf notice that same was
not playing with that on block of wood
he planned to let her rocket its
entirety but after all of the patients
and all of the backs he found an opening
only to have the symphony called upon
him
Oh back to back to back
oh that's a big leap is death yep it's
dunzo son Zoey look at that we are
moving party wolf is gonna be able to
round someone who actually just died
yeah you actually like your Hellboy you
could look at it maybe one more song
because it's gonna be going bad you beat
the director of this movie like alright
we're gonna need another IV yeah let's
go
look at this house under the yellow not
the same in good position because he's
giving it the wall positioning as well
yeah looking for the big launch
I think grab great recognition for
portable fair or the faint realize that
it was gonna be nothing doing even if
there was it like you were gonna get the
punished anyway saying tried to save
that the best he could but instead
looking for a very smart throw follow
I'm getting some combos and you know I
think we see more bags and leave some
hits but pops it once again access the
dart killing it just runs up and good
Wow okay alright and that's not me this
one way to get rid of it know for sure
probably wolves definitely on another
level yeah mentally here a wanted oh if
that hit oh my gosh maybe they'd hit st.
did not take advantage tights world this
is big this is a decisive ground because
whoever gets this is gonna be up in the
lead nice blocking that situation even
though a whiffed party was ready for it
oh that's a little too shoulda chain it
as a very least yeah no big deal there I
guess it's about the outside another 60
days party was gonna go into her early
immediately and get lethal hit Lord the
big stuff because see was already
outside of the first frames yeah that
probably was not according to plan there
he try to get it with the big guard
right there was gonna have to try to
find an opening some other way because
this ain't it st. with the control in
sole charge the entire time just kind of
keep it the dog you know at bay just
back up please no I don't want to play
with you right now here's a toe tap I
said get back it's not time and I'm
saying unaffected
I've bothered other booths by the metal
he's gonna stick to killing so you have
to right
this puts them in a situation where yes
to the two street matches party will
pass it with two street matches if he
wants to make it into our good ok good
if you want to play this game let's
continue all punished now and this is
exactly where party wolf wants to wiggle
stick down I hear it gets TX Tinto and
tap on some extra of any low damage and
again now stained with the avenged to
see wooden doesn't it all you forgot
about this move they're having fun going
up top
little stick busting your way through Oh
too close for that I'm not sure that was
a input error or a guy either way lays
it down runs up steps on up a little
worst in the bag Oh two times can I see
a third one now freak attack instead
want to stay on the offensive foot
school watch your legs so old cotton
over there as well
push him back the other way down bad
position you have to watch out how he
places himself to the wall look look at
that follow up mix up what you got
uh-huh I got just Franks and they follow
up and that's that Marty wolf quickly
trying to tie it up here
EasyWeb punished in that situation and
all of this added up this five hit combo
there to set things off right back at
you got a soul charge pop to get out of
this situation of a party wolf ever the
aggress are gonna run right back in
there and try to get what was lost but
unfortunately this round is gonna be
what's lost same still trying to of
course capitalize here maybe want to
close it out a little bit early for
party horse fighting for his winner's
bracket position yeah party was still in
a very good position here has one and a
half either and it's gonna get another
one if st. survives this round anyway so
yes so can't even play with we'll see
how he decides to utilize those
resources but for now we need to check
this offense because this is how you
fire - life differential but right now
he does put himself into the people or
awakens - my god this thing's in trouble
now oh that's gonna get hit and look at
that that is gonna close on the route
party wolf is gonna tie it off guarantee
yep where'd he go where'd he go
evaporating
party rope out of Boston for being a
legend when the soul said had done I
want use this face right yeah that is
focus right there
focus I'm going to game five whether two
out of three three no difference
whatsoever the drama ensues the drama
continues just machito set things up or
kill it's a little too old to present
stop think about him a long time ago
doesn't matter if it's two out of three
three out of five we've been going all
the way tease them up there just to get
up in right quick and the brain contact
just hits wall that's wrong what's a
looking for maybe a sidestep put a bit
too late with that movement option kick
stay down yeah working towards the
corner now this could be crucial gets
the grab but a good tech space between
those two we couldn't win a little
bigger but it's a it gets to lift anyway
actually that's a very solid that turns
out Danny's right into the optical stuff
just below pull you win kids are
throwing the sidestep seven seconds on
the clock in st. it's gonna come down
crashing from the heavens vertical
attacks just Anya knocking don't you
support you it had to be a slow pay for
that pretty parties not having a
defeater not able to stop it for the
time room they didn't even feel like
that was a fifty pretty psycho match
that's the thing right now party was in
the red this is good positioning for
same for the rest of the matchup here
let's see what he does okay had a poppy
ring out opportunity peak time
opportunity for seen here though if you
can secure this round and keep the
Guardians there it's just one or the
other at this point if it can happen
employed the devil just starting to rack
up oh man he got him on wake up to ya
later though my gosh this is huge and
st. taking advantage of that situation
wait a minute game party whooping
opening he has a chance
alright so charge is now depleting but
oh my god picks little pixel packed and
anybody gonna take a risk
now party was gonna gain a little bit he
could eat a poke at most but not a
full-fledged joint like that it's just
like that saying one round away what
moving on it's all my guns two clutches
love it out oh this this feels like one
of those classics hanging around it's
about that but no party wolf all the
denial wait a minute it's a different
type of tournament balls only one of us
is getting through so I'm gonna pull out
all the stops as well up ready mohnish
quit will stick counter hit stun oh he
was ready for it he knew there was gonna
be an attempt there there you go nice
bait trying to get the tech trap set up
I gotta follow anything just gonna stay
right outside of this rink I don't want
anything to do what you what it is st.
popping in sole charge just thousand
this time trying to get rid of this old
charges quickens pop and it didn't need
any other resources able to keep his
meter as well big advantage stayin alive
and going into the absolutely deny table
that slide it in words
let's play of course the party will put
Eddie continue this momentum right now
he is been looking it out watch your
legs
uh-huh oh and a big follow-up here this
is one of those situations where just
everything is working and when it stop
he immediately popped this old truck
check it ahead Oh God when party wolf
knows he knows
also dead by oh so good yeah yeah he
denied Christmas by you is it not
happening today no Thanksgiving comes
first all right party well fighting for
the respect of other holidays after it's
not we've seen it before there's a point
so start things off because he got the
Stono that he just the extension Oh
break attack yeah you had no choice here
same soul charging to get out of there
jumps over the reeds your party will
bring out all of the hardest camp it's
like I this is gonna work you know
cheese everything contains gonna have to
be very very careful I was gonna attack
here and this is gonna land really big
it's gonna damage yes but I don't think
he's dead I do not think he's dead but
it's not at this time but still like
you're in a position where our party
wolf has the advantage and the world one
is illegal here and that should be
enough on the tongue yes party wolf and
fancy get to the grand finals that's
right that's all you have to say that's
it that's right y'all know what time it
is shaped by hand cert and good luck on
the other side now a scene has to get
ready to run the accelerated gauntlet
he's either gonna get rich takes our
pool next but before that those two have
to face each other
ding what is said between those two man
you know party will had to come from
behind obviously he was already down the
comeback p-dogs he is a knocking on the
door sitting in the greatest spot you
possibly could the winner side it's not
just 23 more three or five any other set
to give well that's the thing too he's
looking at all the players he respects
him you can tell he's having some insane
matches but he's letting them know you
guys aren't my opponents my opponents
are other said my eyes when I'm killing
you that's how I feel when I watch party
wolf you understand so